question I think the question people
should be asking themselves is what am i
doing to ensure that the world I leave
behind the country alley behind the
society I leave behind is better than
the one I found how can I ensure that
people who are coming after me have the
same or better opportunities than I did
how can I demonstrate by the way I live
my life that I have respect for the
views of others and I'm willing to
listen to others and I and I and I have
a the integrity to accept good ideas
from others even if their ideas that
didn't conform to my preconceived
notions those the kinds of things I
think people ought to be asking
themselves about they the way they live
their lives if you if you are willing to
live your life in a way so that when
people look back on your life where you
look back on it yourself you can say I
did the best I could do to to leave the
world or society or my country better
than I found it
hey